where do we
find Our Lord depicted as the Passover
Lamb and why is that significant guys I
promise you you're in for a treat you'll
be blown away how indepth the Bible is
how miraculous it is and how it all
points to Jesus it's all about Jesus
anyone tell me
where can anyone tell me
come on guys I want to engage you this
is a class
setting nope not John
129 I was hoping someone quote John
129 where is Jesus set to be the
Passover Lamb going to
Exodus will only land you in trouble can
you show me where in Exodus it says
Jesus is the Passover Lamb can you show
me in Leviticus where it says Jesus is
the Passover Lamb even in Isaiah 53
though we know that's Jesus it doesn't
say Jesus it doesn't say Christ it
doesn't say son of God it doesn't say
son of David right even if it said Son
of David Son of God it still wouldn't
tell us from the Old Testament
perspective that's
Jesus obviously the answer must be found
in the New Testament because there is
where we now learn the identity of the
servant of Isaiah 53 and the anointed
king who will sit on David's Throne he
is Jesus of Nazareth but the name
Jesus the title Jesus of
Nazareth or the title Jesus the Christ
are not found in the Old Testament zeala
got
it an Arabian princess who's quoting
zealous got it it's in 1 Corinthians
57 no it's not John
129 where John says the Lamb of God who
takes away the sins of the world it's 1
Corinthians 5 verse 7 but not only 1
Corinthians 5 ver7 it's also found
somewhere else now I was hoping someone
would mention John
1:29 the reason why I said no that's not
the passage because there the Greek
word that's used is amnos
now that that word
omnos right is
used in Isaiah 53 in the Greek versions
of Isaiah 53 called the
sepen so that word omnos is used there
so in John 1 129 where it says Behold
the Lamb of God who takes away the sin
of the world that is actually alluding
to Isaiah 53 because there when they
translated Isaiah 53 into Greek they use
the word amnos when it talks about a
lamb being led to the
slaughter and in that passage he does
take away the sin of the world but the
problem with citing John 129 to identify
Jesus as the Passover Lamb is that the
Passover Lamb did not take away
sin did you know that
Exodus 12 the Passover Lamb did not take
away
sin the Passover
L isn't a
sacrifice to atone for
sin but in John 1:29 Jesus is a lamb
that does take away
sin so you cannot connect John 129 with
the Passover Lamb because the Passover
Lamb did not take away the sin of God's
people it wasn't a vicarious
substitutionary atoning
sacrifice so where is Jesus set to
be our Passover well first it's 1
Corinthians 5:7 but it's also found in
another
place in another
place a place that again if if you don't
have access to a good commentary or you
can't read the Greek you won't see it
there are two Greek words used to
describe Jesus as the lamb omnos which I
just mentioned John 129 but then there's
another
word and this is the
word used in Revelation five and
Revelation 7 and throughout the Book of
Revelation there in Revelation five in
verse six we are told that John saw a
lamb and the Greek word is
Aron Arion sorry for butchering the
Greek and all these facts are in these
articles by the way so you don't need to
do the research it's there it's in
Revelation 5 Verse 6 and in subsequent
chapters of Revelation where John calls
Jesus Aron
Aron that is a different Greek word than
omnos so in John 129 John the Baptist
says Behold the Lamb of God who takes
away the sin of the world which John
renders in Greek as omnos lamb
omnos but the word that John uses in
Revelation by inspiration of the holy
spirit is not omnos it's Aron Aron you
know why that's
significant can anyone help me let's see
if you're you're listening cuz
class class has begun we need to listen
as the cat needs
attention Okay why is that significant
because the word omnos just refers to a
lamb in
general whereas the word Aron why is
that significant guys help me
out the word
Aron right the word
Aron refers to a young male
lamb and the Passover Lamb was a young
male
lamb that was one year old so Jesus is
depicted as a young lamb a young male
lamb Holy Spirit saved me from error
right a young male lamb so there by
using this word lamb Aron which refers
to a young lamb obviously a male lamb
because Jesus is a male there John is
depicting Jesus or Jesus is appearing as
the Passover Lamb that had been slain
but is still
alive thank you thank you what the heck
he just quoted the Greek of John 56
notice what the word is used for the
Passover feast do you guys see it he
quoted it for you what is the word used
for the past pass over Feast
AR so it's 1 Corinthians
5:7 and Revelation
56 where Jesus is identified as our
Passover Lamb now why is that
important here's why it's important why
is that important if there's a Passover
Lamb that's slain that means means
there's a new Exodus Now watch how the
New Testament depicts the story of
redemption a Passover Lamb slain right
there that's a clue for you who think
biblically being illuminated by the
spirit wait if there's a Passover slame
that means there's an exodus of God's
people well if there's an exodus of
God's people that means there is a new
pharaoh and a new Egypt that has Place
God's people in bondage so God has now
redeemed his people from bondage
bringing them out of the
Tyranny out from the tyranny of pharaoh
and from the land of bondage which means
that God's people are now going through
a Wilderness as they make their way to
Canaan you with me
there so Jesus being the Passover Lamb
slain means a new Exodus is occurring an
exodus of a new people of God being
taken out from a new Egypt under the
tyranny of a new Pharaoh as they go
through a new Wilderness on their way to
Canaan why do you
think God's Heavenly Abode is called
Heavenly
Jerusalem why do you think in Hebrews
12:22 to 24 we are told that in heaven
you have a Mount Zion
and that God's Heavenly Abode where
glorified Believers dwell with the
glorified Christ and Angels beholding
God the Father invisible form that's
called Heavenly Jerusalem Hebrews 12:22
to 24 why do you think in Galatians
4:26 we are told that there's a
Jerusalem that's above and that
Jerusalem is our mother why do you think
in Revelation
21 you are told there's a Heavenly
Jerusalem which is the Bride of the lamb
and this heavenly Jerusalem comes down
to the
Earth are you with me
there so let's connect the dots as we go
in depth if you're interested we're
going to go
slowly and show how even The Exodus
points to Jesus his
Redemption the birth of the church being
taken out of captivity going through a
Wilderness as they head to towards
Heavenly Canaan Heavenly
Jerusalem okay so follow with
me if there's an
exodus there's a Passover Lamb if
there's a Passover Lamb there is a
covenant and there is a liberator and
there is a
lawgiver and there is a conqueror
because notice in the first Exodus you
had Moses The Liberator who is the
lawgiver who made a covenant with God's
people but that people also had a
conqueror who conquered their enemies as
he brought them in to the land of
promise the land of Canaan who was that
conqueror who was that
conqueror who is the one who brought
Israel out of the Wilderness into the
land of res Canan and destroyed their
enemies before them so they can inherit
the land and
rest Joshua right ah now let's go into
the me all right Numbers chapter
13:8 and Numbers Chapter 13 verse1 16
are you
ready Numbers Chapter 13 Verse 8 numbers
13:16 this should blow you away did you
know
that Joshua's original name was
hosia and it was changed to Joshua here
you go numbers
13:8 from the tribe of Ephraim hosia son
of n his name was hosia wasn't
originally Joshua so what happened well
numbers
13:16 these were the names of the men
whom Moses sent to spy out the land and
Moses changed the name of hos
son of noon to
Joshua did you catch
that did you catch
that hosia son of noon had his name
changed to Joshua by Moses why did Moses
change his name to Joshua let's go into
samit Joshua and Hebrews yosua yahoshua
the abbreviated form of that name is
Yeshua Yeshua and you'll find that in
Ezra chter 3 verse2 and Ezra
5:2 the shorten form of yahoshua
yahoshua
is Yeshua and yahushua means Jehovah is
salvation
why did
God move Moses to change hosia to Joshua
because Joshua's name change signifies
that Jehovah would save his people
through the agency of Joshua in other
words he was called Jesus because in
Greek the Greek versions of the Hebrew
Bible yahushua is translated as yes
Yus so his name was deliberately changed
to Jesus because he's a picture of Jesus
to
come that's why when you read sirak 46
verse1 guess what you read sirak 46
verse1 if you read the Greek version of
sirak the word Joshua is yesus and I'll
give you a link to prove that Joshua son
of new
was mighty in war and was the successor
of Moses in the prophetic office he
became note he became as his name
implies a great savior of God's elect to
take Vengeance on the enemies that Rose
against them so that he might give
Israel its inheritance you see what it
said he became what his name implied he
would be
a great
savior at sirak 46 verse1 now let me get
you the English translation of sirak and
the Greek right next to
it are you with me so far or no am I
putting you to sleep you want me to end
it I'll end it because I'm only here to
be used of the spirit to bless you and
if I'm blessing you we'll continue watch
here sirak you see why you Protestants
are missing out so so much Gems diamonds
and meat because you don't read theal
chonicles because of your bias against
it here it is English translation of
sirak and its Greek text right next to
it watch here go to verse one guess how
this English translation renders the
Greek Jesus the son a
Nave because if you look at the Greek
text you'll see the words
in all right here it is the
Greek
yesus no yesus na
na na Nave okay man I have a hard time
speaking English you guys want me to
speak Greek come on
dude okay is it a
coincidence
hosia had his name changed
to Joshua which is
yosua which in Greek is yesus which is
the name of our Lord and Savior Jesus
Christ a name that signifies that Joshua
is the savior that God raised up to save
Israel by destroying their enemies and
causing them to inherit the land of rest
now let's take it a step
further John
117 I gave you the link to this
translation here it is
again John
11:7 okay are you
ready let me show you this get ready to
really be blown away You're gonna say
come on man you're making stuff up John
1:17
now I can use the new King James version
because I don't need the chonicles here
it is New King James version for the law
was given through Moses but Grace and
Truth came through Jesus Christ so
notice Moses represents the
Law Moses represents the Law Jesus
embodies God's favor and Truth notice it
wasn't Moses that brought Israel into
the land of rest because by by the law
no man shall enter God's
rest it was Jesus that brought them into
the land of
rest you caught
it Moses who repres represents the Law
could not bring Israel into the land of
rest because by the law no one shall
enter into rest it is only by the saving
work the salvation of Jesus that you
will enter so God already had designed
it back then to show Israel by Moses you
cannot enter my rest you can only enter
my rest by the grace of
Jesus man why like this man why like
this why like this
now let me give you couple more
nuggets are you ready for a couple more
nuggets
okay Exodus 17: 1-7 I'm not going to
quote it okay I'm not going to quote it
I'm just going to sum it
up the Israelites started complaining
there was no water in the
desert and God told Moses to go by the
rock there was a rock in the wilderness
he goes take the rod in your hand the
staff in your hand strike the Rock and
water will gush forth from the rock to
satisfy the Israelites thirst okay now
fast
forward in time years later the
Israelites again
complain about having no water Numbers
Chapter 20 verses
1-13 God says to Moses this time speak
to the
Rock I will stand by The Rock if you
read numbers 20: 1-13 God says Jehovah
says I'll stand by The Rock speak to the
Rock and water will gush forth in other
words command it and water will gush
forth it says Moses in his rashness out
of his anger struck the rock twice out
of his anger he goes to the Israelites
you who keep complaining here you go
Papa and water came forth
Jehovah got angry with
Moses and Jehovah told Moses you did not
honor me in the sight of the people
because I told you to speak to the Rock
instead you Struck it twice Therefore
your punishment is you're going to die
in the wilderness I'll let you see the
land from afar but you won't enter now
the reason why this is significant is
because in John 7
38-39 and 1
Corinthians 10 veres 1-4 let's read it
let's see if you make the connection
Anna Chong is making the connection our
sister's excited so she's posting the
answer before we get to it because she's
excited it's all right it's all right
logos John 7
38-39 he who believes in me as the
scripture has said out of his heart will
flow rivers of Living Water but but this
he spoke concerning the spirit whom
those believing in him in Jesus would
receive for the Holy Spirit was not yet
given because Jesus was not yet
glorified notice Jesus gives you the
fountain the spring of Living Water the
Waters of life which is the holy spirit
because of Jesus when you trust in him
he will then pour out the spirit to fill
you and satisfy your thir spiritually
forever and ever now how did Jesus do
that how did Jesus do that by his death
on the cross his death on the cross
procured our
Redemption and the gift of the Holy
Spirit of
life okay but watch here
now can you crucify Christ more than
once no Hebrews 6: 4-6 States you cannot
crucify Christ over again Christ was
crucified only once for our Salvation
you don't keep crucifying
him so now watch what 1 Corinthians 10
verses 1-4 says pay attention Guys 1
Corinthians 10 veres 1- 4 moreover
Brethren I do not want you to be unaware
that all our fathers were under the
cloud that pillar of cloud by
day all passed through the sea when this
see was split all were baptized immersed
United under the headship of Moses
baptized into Moses and in the cloud and
in the sea came under Moses the cloud
and the
Sea all ate the same spiritual food and
all drank the same spiritual drinks so
they were not being physically nourished
only they're also being spiritually
nourished for they drank out of that
spiritual rock that followed them and
that rock was Christ
wow the one that fed them not just
physically and spiritually and the one
that quenched their thirst not just
physically spiritually was Christ
because Christ is that spiritual rock
that was there with them in the cloud
following them guiding them preserving
them how do you make the connection
that physical rock that Moses struck was
a picture of Jesus AR Rock being struck
on the cross to give
us Living
Waters and the living bread to satisfy
us forever that's why the first time
Jehovah says strike the rock but the
second time he says speak to it
why because you don't need to strike it
more than once once is enough for that
rock to give you everlasting
life so by striking the rock again he
was crucifying Christ over again which
is sin
okay can we continue a little
further can we go a little more into
this wait wait shut the front door I'm
done so thank you Holy Spirit for
leading us to the depth of your word for
the glory of Jesus let me give you
something else that's not in my notes
Exodus
178 to6 the amalaki ites hinder the
Israelites in the wilderness and oppose
them watch this guys get ready to be
blown away and this was an Insight that
I found in Justin
Martyr this Insight I found in the
writings of Justin Martyr as he was
showing how Jesus Is prefigured In These
Old Testament historical events so what
you're learning here is this is real
history it's not myth this is not fables
these are real historical events
but these historical events that took
that occurred in time and place were
designed in such a way to point to
Future historical events and greater
spiritual realities now watch
here watch here okay Exodus 17 8-16 note
after Moses strikes The Rock notice this
make the connection it's in the same
chapter he hits the rock with the rod
water gushes forth notice The Rock has
been struck The Rock has been
slain
immediately it says the amalekites
opposed Israelites and hinder them and
went to war it says Moses went on a
mound on a
hill and Joshua with the army of Israel
was fighting in the lower land against
the amalik ites and now notice what it
says it says when Moses stretched out
his arms Joshua would win but as he
tired and his arms started
falling the amalekites would get the
upper hand so it says Moses sat on a
stone and Aaron on one side and whoore
on the other helped him stretch out his
hand and as long as he was on the stone
on a hill with his hands stretched out
Joshua defeated the enemies of
God okay did you catch it three working
together to bring about the salvation of
God's people from their enemies and
Jesus is leading the battle destroying
the enemies of God
and how is Jesus winning by outstretched
arms as a sign of the
cross and notice he's sitting on a stone
and Jesus in 1 Peter 2 is set to be the
stone that the builders rejected
right okay and he's on a mound on a hill
right and Jesus was crucified on a mound
shaped like a skull called
Golgotha in fact do me a favor take a
moment and look at it don't take my word
for it Exodus 178 to16 am I making it up
on a hill sits on a stone Aon and her
stretch out his hands that's three three
working together three
working together to bring about the
Redemption of God's people from their
enemies and who's leading the Army to
destroy God's enemies
Jesus and how is Jesus winning by
outstretched Arms by the cross